[music]
hello i am more open from der leyen and
i would be president of
the european commission for the next five years
no that is 500 million people in
28 countries with 24 different languages
a top team with my commission from
ll regions of europe and we wa
t  use all our
strength for europe and for its people these people want a strong
economy that creates jobs and sustainable
prosperity they want europe
to become a climate-neutral continent
and to be successful in the digital age
they expect protection for the weak
and security for everyone
they want investments  in education and
research and innovation
because that creates the opportunities for tomorrow for us europeans, the rule of
law and democracy are paramount
and they want a self-confident
europe that is a good neighbor and a
good
partner we feel
committed to these goals let's get to work